Thanks Dr. Granstein for having me and I'm happy to join.
I'm Chelsey Richards at CDC.
I'm the Deputy Director for Public Health Scientific Services,
and I also direct the Office of Public Health Scientific Services.
Sure. So I am a physician.
I'm an internal medicine physician and geriatric physician.
I started my professional life after medical school and residency in a medical school,
running a division of general medicine and seeing patients.
I saw about 70 patients a week.
And I think after several years of this,
I noticed that patients from rural Georgia were coming in with health problems,
were they had never had any preventive service for that, or any screening.
And it led me to thinking more about there ought to be ways to intervene beyond
just the intervention at an individual level which I did as a clinician,
but more at a population or community level,
and that's what brought me with an interest into public health.
I went and got additional schooling,
a Master's in public health.
And then, came to CDC as an Epidemic Intelligence Service officer,
which a lot of people at CDC come in.
And for that two year fellowship, we went,
we got sent all over the place to investigate disease outbreaks.
I went to Los Angeles.
I went to South America,
I went to Japan, I went to Taiwan.
In really investigating sort of an emerging problem,
being able to quickly identify what the causes were and intervene.
And that was very fulfilling and has really been why I've stayed
in public health the last 20 years.
Well, CDC is a federal agency.
It's located in Atlanta. It's the only federal agency
that's headquartered out of the Washington D.C. area.
We have about 15000 employees and a large budget.
And we have staff in every state in the U.S. and 60 countries.
And our mission is, to protect the safety,
health safety of Americans and globally.
And also, to promote prevention and health promotion.
Well, public health surveillance,
is the foundation of everything we do in public health.
And really what it is, is collecting data,
health data, to understand the burden,
the trends and what interventions really impact on health.
It's key to our preparedness as a nation to prevent health safety adverse events.
It's also key for understanding trends like obesity and other chronic diseases and what
interventions help us ameliorate these chronic diseases.
So public health surveillance,
as we were saying, is the foundation.
That data is the foundation of what we do in public health,
to know when to act,
where to act, what to do.
And most of our data in public health surveillance comes from the health care system.
And historically and traditionally,
that's been often a paper process,
where a doctor has to fill out a form by hand and
then maybe send it by mail or fax to a health department.
And then, a health department takes that and has to put it into a database to analyze it.
We're moving rapidly with electronic health records to an all electronic environment.
And I think the exciting thing for public health is that,
the speed with which we can get data now,
allows us to take much quicker action to prevent disease outbreaks,
or to address in local communities specific pockets
of health problems or health conditions or diseases.
So I think, electronic health records and the ability to move data in
a digital format very fluidly between local clinicians,
hospitals, their local health departments,
their state health departments and CDC,
it's going to revolutionize the way public health can really protect
and support health promotion.
So, what this diagram really illustrates is the interconnectedness between health care,
public health, and many of the social factors that influence health.
And CDC and state and local health departments sit in that interface,
between the clinical system and the social,
what we call the social determinants of health.
And I think, what inner informatics and electronic health records
have the opportunity to give us,
is much better data moving between these various parts of the system.
So for example,
a huge public health problem we have in this country is the control of blood pressure.
We have about a third of the country has high blood pressure and
really controlling blood pressure is going to be so
critical to decrease deaths from heart disease and stroke.
Well, there's a clinical portion to that,
which is a doctor being able to recognize high blood pressure,
being able to prescribe medications for a patient to
take those medications and get blood pressure under control.
And that's information and data that's generated in the clinical system.
And health departments are very interested in that.
But we also know that things like,
access to good food, income, housing,
occupation, work, there are a lot of social factors that influence
on a person's ability to have normal blood pressure.
And having more data which has been lacking for public health and for clinical medicine,
more data about that,
is going to help us understand,
where interventions in those social determinants
might have an impact on a particular help problem like high blood pressure.
Likewise, we understand, that for clinicians and for health departments for example,
with high blood pressure,
there was a medication that has to be prescribed
and we have to ensure that people are taking those medications.
And so, some of those data streams from pharmacies and from
other sources and increasingly from wearables that people,
devices that people wear that would monitor blood pressure.
As that data becomes available to the health care system and
public health it enables both of us to be able to
do more to get people to normal blood pressure.
So that's just one example of a health problem that is going to be
impacted dramatically by this movement of data,
from the various sectors I've discussed.
Yes. So, public health,
the foundation of public health is data and
surveillance data and analytics have been critical for
us to advance our understanding of health and to intervene and improve health.
Epidemiology has been sort of the bedrock science within public health.
And traditional epidemiology looks for data to support causality of disease and then,
where trends of disease are going.
I think we have lacked in public health and in clinical medicine,
the ability to look at data in a big data context and really
be able to integrate all these various streams of data just mentioned.
And so, I think we're just beginning to learn in public health,
sort of the types of tools that are going to be needed,
in order to turn these vast amounts of data into knowledge that we can use.
And one thing that's critical to understand about public health and
the work that CDC does is that,
the work we do around data and analytics is not just to generate knowledge,
it's not just research.
But it's really data for action.
And we really have to take action at a local level,
at a regional level, state or national level or global level,
on the data analytics that we use.
So, as we become more comfortable with the big data analytic tools,
I think it's going to enable,
unleash a whole set of opportunities for us to
take better action when it needs to be more precise,
or bigger action globally, to really improve health.
One challenge that I'm concerned about is, signal to noise.
And so, when we think about big data analytics for example,
finding a signal in those big data may be
an important finding for us to be able to intervene early.
But what if it signals not quite right?
What if it's an association with a health problem,
but it's really not causing the problem?
And so, a lot of our work in epidemiology and surveillance is really not only
looking for associations between a signal and a disease,
or an outcome, but ensuring to
some extent that that signals really related in a real way,
because we're going to take action on that.
And so, that signal to noise problem is I think a real one.
I think, there are tools within
data analytics that will allow us to understand that better.
Machine learning, and other approaches
we're going to have to become more comfortable with,
to really harness the value there,
but that problem is going to still be one we're going to have to deal with.
I think another big issue that's relevant to your class and to the students,
who are taking these courses, is the workforce.
Most of our workforce and public health have been trained on
very traditional epidemiologic and other data analytical approaches.
We need a new fresh workforce that's going to have the tools
and experience with some of the newer tools of bigger data analytics.
And I think, how we bring people into public health is something I think about every day.
One thing that separates us from maybe the private sector,
we don't have maybe some of the incomes,
but we have a mission that is really compelling.
Because everyday, when we come in to work,
we're trying to save lives.
We're trying to prevent disability.
We're trying to promote health.
We're impacting not only people in our community,
but people all over the world.
And so, people who come to public health and really love it,
are there for that mission.
I think, one of the things that has been striking
with fire is the good enough syndrome, I would say.
We have in public health a tradition of wanting to get things just perfect,
before we're comfortable with the way collect data.
And that delays our ability to get the data we need to take action.
And so, what's nice about fire in the modular concepts that are embedded in fire is,
we can get going. We can get data.
And as we learn more about a condition,
and many of our health conditions or disease outbreaks or epidemics are evolving,
so we're learning all the time.
We can improve that standard with other modular pieces and get more refined data,
but we don't have to delay our ability to get the data before we have it perfect.
So, the perfect is often the enemy of the good.
Let me try that again. The perfect is often the enemy of the good for us.
And I think fire fits into a model,
where we really need rapid data that we can analyze and act on.
So, I think that's a fantastic question,
because I've talked mostly about data,
but the other side of public health is this action that I keep talking about.
And I think apps offer us an opportunity to not only
harness the data that's there to tell us something about health or disease or epidemics,
but to immediately act.
To be able to send information back,
and tools back to that clinician to take action in the office.
To send it to public health.
To have information that can be from a local health department,
or a state health department.
Refine and into the hands of a clinician to be able to
counsel a patient on a health behavior issue.
So I think, apps really are an important part of the future for intervention,
which is again key to what we do. Great, thank you very much.